well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored Britain's had
its fair share of failed politicians
lately Boris Johnson lied more often
than he tried a last prime minister Liz
truss had the shelf life are they
lettuce and Theresa May's Legacy if only
we could remember it would fit very
neatly onto a postage stamp but few
politicians in modern history have
failed harder and more often than Matt
Hancock there's attention seeking
perma-grinning gopher of a man is about
to appear on I'm a celebrity get me out
of here that means he'll spend several
weeks in a jungle in Australia pocketing
a massive fee on top of his MP salary
eating kangaroo testicles of public
detention I never thought I'd say this
but I actually feel sorry for the
kangaroo testicles I spent six years as
a judge on Britain and America's Got
Talent so another thing or two about
entertainment TV and talent it got me
thinking why would they choose Matt
Hancock what are his special talents
maybe maybe it's singing
[Music]
under the Jesus
[Music]
Don't Stop Me Now for the love of God do
stop him now he's not a singer what
about acting look very carefully here
look for Tears
it's just simple words there reacting it
you're quite emotional about that well
it's just it's been you know it's been
such a tough year for so many people and
there's William Shakespeare putting it
simply for everybody that you know we
can get on with our lives and yeah not a
single tear was it I've seen more
emotion from the wax works that Madame
tussos Matt's also a budding Tex whiz he
became the first MP to enter the
metaverse with this digital imagining of
himself bringing a whole new level of
meaning to Instagram versus reality
so finally what about his actual core
skill the one thing we know that he is
supposed to be competent at being a
politician the thing he's paid to do
well he was forced out as health
secretary for Snogging and groping his
advisor during a lockdown breaking his
own lockdown rules and before about a
sales secretary during the pandemic he
said he was doing this to protect
nursing homes
so right from the start we've tried to
throw a protective ring around our Care
Homes well we absolutely did throw a
protective ring around social care we'll
keep working to strengthen the
protective ring that we've cast around
all our Care Homes absolute nonsense
there was no protective ring quite the
opposite Hancock sent thousands of
elderly patients and hospitals back to
their nursing homes without testing them
that led to covid spreading the Wildfire
inside of those homes causing countless
more deaths than she'd ever been allowed
to happen it was a deadly Fiasco of a
policy from a travesty of a health
secretary with tragic consequences for
thousands of families I may shock you
now Mr Hancock because I'm actually glad
you're going to remote
tarantula-infested jungle on the
opposite side of the world on behalf of
the entire British public I think I'm
safe in saying I hope you stay there
well joining me now to discuss is a
former liberal Democrat MP lemon oh
picky also went into I'm a celebrity and
the former conservative Minister and
Whitaker who I presume would rather
shoot herself than go into the jungle
though she did compete here strictly and
extremely capably on the dancer I might
add we're also joined by care home owner
David Crabtree now 16 of his residents
died in the first wave of the pandemic
uh well welcome to all of you I want to
start with you David Crouch because I
remember interviewing you at the heights
of the pandemic when so many people were
dying and you gave such a heartfelt uh
and agonized interview in many ways
about uh the appalling situation in Care
Homes when you heard that Matt Hancock
is going into the I'm a celebrity jungle
uh while you're still an MP what was
your view
before I I comment on that uh appears
can I thank you personally for being the
lone voice in early 2020 for social care
workers and social care residents there
was no one more shouting for us
as to Mr Hancock it's the last pitiful
Act of a pathetic lying man
there was no ring no protection for us
what's emotional is that when somebody
brings this up again
it brings back all the things that you
you sort of put to the back of your mind
we only this month we're able to have a
memorial for those who died in 2020
simply because relatives weren't allowed
to go to their funerals we weren't
allowed to see the relatives so for two
years we've never seen those families
again so we've just been able to sort of
at least bring that to a conclusion but
as to Mr Hancock
he lied there is no two ways about this
he lied 850 social care workers died on
top of thousands of elderly there were
collateral damage someone with his
permission gave the uh hospitals the
report to say you can discharge and the
with the without a negative test
they do not need to be negative to
discharge they discharge two to us uh
within the first week of March and both
died and subsequently a further seven
died as a result of those discharges
directly this man
oversaw this is this is Blair's Iraq
this is Hancock's uh death of elderly he
is solely responsible for it I'm still
angry
I can tell and you know you know what
angers me about all this is that while
some people have been sort of laughing
about this you know extraordinary twist
to his career it emerged today he's also
been taking part in the celebrity uh SAS
show on channel four he's already filmed
that he's also written a book of his
pandemic Diaries which I'm sure will be
an attempt to gloss over any of his
culpability because it wasn't just about
girls he also failed and lied to the
public about testing he massaged those
figures about the number of tests that
were being done and we held him to
account for that I thought our open
border policy was a complete disaster
and he was partly responsible for that
as well as health secretary we had no
PPE so hundreds and hundreds of Health
and Care workers died in their workplace
because they weren't properly protected
this this first wave of the pandemic in
our country was a complete disaster and
it's completely true to say that later
we did well with vaccines but that first
wave was a disaster and the health
secretary presiding over this was Matt
Hancock and for him to now before
there's even been a proper inquiry into
what happened and what culpability he
may actually be proven to have had for
him to now go into an a reality show in
a jungle in the way that he's doing for
hundreds of thousands of pounds I think
is an absolute smack in the face
particularly to people like you who had
to go through so much appalling trauma
losing all these people in your homes
and I know other people I have friends
of mine who lost their parents in Care
Homes and had to have a last
conversation on FaceTime you know I just
think it's an appalling smack in the
face to them and and the idea he's not
an MP receiving an MP salary is
completely disgraceful
I I couldn't agree more I I don't know
whether this is to pay the divorce
settlements or what it's supposed to do
but in the end it it should have all he
had to do was was say that we we
couldn't do it or there was some reason
that they couldn't do it but instead
contracts were rewarded for PPE that
were no use to us we couldn't get them
more importantly they were discharging
elderly people to Hope back to home
where home care workers were going in
without PPE without the knowledge that
they had that the resident had covered
he put at risk
millions of people and then denied it
and and had the blessed to stand there
and say he had put a ring of protection
around us not once but several times the
man needs to be held account yeah I
agree uh David it's good to talk to you
I wish it was always in better
circumstances but I love your passion I
love the how much you care about what
happened in your care homes and it's
good to catch up with you and I'm just
sorry again it's for the wrong reasons
but I look forward to talking to you
perhaps on a happier occasion
thank you
well let's bring in I mean and yeah I
don't know what you think to me the idea
of an MP particularly one who's been
disgraced who's lost his ministerial
position because he was breaking his own
lockdown rules whilst having an affair
and was caught doing it by uh by a
newspaper that had also presided over a
shambolic first wave of this pandemic by
any yardstick there's been no inquiry
yet which has cleared him as he
presumably hopes it might do but I don't
think it will you put all this in
totality and he's now
getting hundreds of thousands of pounds
to go into a jungle and prance about
with celebrities what do you make of it
well what I would say is that even
without all those horrendous
circumstances no serving MP should go on
a reality show which takes them away
from their constituency and from the
House of Commons where they're paid to
vote uh it takes them away for weeks on
it I mean you know weekend here at a
week that's different weeks on end and
that is why I turned down strictly for
five years running I said no as soon as
I retired I said yes because I wanted to
do it but I wasn't going to do it while
I was an MP and it's not only time that
something else appears dignity you do
actually have a duty of dignity to the
office while you're an MP and there's
nothing dignified about the job well
okay what about his constituents right
this guy is already heaped embarrassment
onto his constituency right he's managed
to hang on as an MP uh but this is as I
say not just I'm a celebrity he's
managed to find time to write a book of
Diaries he's managed to find time to do
this SAS Show on Channel 4. now he's
going in the jungle when is he finding
any time to do the job he's actually
paid to do on a daily basis serve the
constituents direct answer to that
question that doesn't matter for his
constituents at the next election and
I've got experience of this I may or may
not have lost my seat in 2010. why isn't
it a matter for me as a taxpayer well if
it pays his salary you can have an
opinion but we have a democratic system
here just as in 2010 Montgomery should
decided they didn't want many more for
whatever reason so also his constituents
in our democratic system can make the
Judgment no I no Anne's position and I
respect it I hold a different view here
you've just heard what sounds like a
tragic performance as a cabinet minister
that's different to the principle which
Anne rightly raises about whether you
should be able to do these extended
programs on reality TV now surely no one
disagrees with the principle of a
politician doing a reality show have I
got news for you it's a comedy show
Vince cable very popular politician did
do a little bit of dancing
have I got used to you it's a three-hour
taping of a Thursday night right this
guy is disappearing off for weeks to
Australia right when we're in the middle
of a crushing cost of living crisis
could be four weeks
all right so the first point it's being
paid by us the taxpayer not to not to go
and eat kangaroo testicles let me ask
you this lemon who is going to cope if
there is an emergency in his
constituency or a constituent has an
emergency where does that constituent go
yeah I work on the assumption that if
there's I and I don't know this but I've
been told this by Secondhand Authority
that there is some clause which says if
there's an emergency of a sufficiently
serious nature which is a judgment call
he would sorry there is it's called the
cost of living all right millions of
people in this country are currently
facing a winter of hunger you know of
freezing tolls we've got pensioners
going on buses
because I I do have experience with this
let me just ask you this a constituent
gets in touch with the MP because the
electricity is about to be cut off
they've got kids in the house this has
happened and it probably happened with
you as well and when that sort of thing
happens you need the MP his staff don't
have the quote right two two points I'm
not switching on TV earlier then
we're trying to answer your questions I
know but you're trying to defend the in
defensive you don't know what I'm going
to say well I do know what you said
earlier on television I watched the
interview you compared him to Winston
Churchill you said Winston Churchill
also made mistakes and came back and won
US the Winston church do you think
Winston Churchill would go into a jungle
with a bunch of zedless celebrities a
Munch kangaroo testicles in a vote by
the public I was one of those that
that's listed yes exactly but I wasn't
nothing yes second but you don't know
Winston Churchill either
I've never pretended to be first point
that let's recognize no one here on the
three of us is denying that you could do
reality shows you're arguing about the
length of time away yes so let's move
straight to that second point that
Anne's raised if you're on holiday with
your family as an MP the same situation
can arise does that mean that the MP has
to fly back okay you can pick up right
so it's not about physically business
holidays
all of us not in recent okay all right
well let's remember that but you can
pick up the phone if you're on holiday
I've had to do that as well okay some
MPS have had to come back from their
holidays so number one it's not about
whether you do reality shows it's the
length of time number two it's not about
being physically present as answer said
so it's the third question is it is
because
you don't have phones in the jungle okay
because vote remotely is that enough of
an obstruction to say that no
politicians should do that yes
absolutely I don't agree but I'm
actually going to tell you most things
that do turn up in your surgery are
handled de facto certainly for
serving members of parliament go on
jollies to Australia
how do you vote from the jungle when
there's a big issue in Poland
well I don't know if he's got a pairing
sound
you can still vote yeah okay so explain
that for me if you have the whip taken
away then you can still you're not
expelled from what's the punishment
really well if if you have the whip
withdrawn what it means is you're no
longer regard it as a member of the
party you can still vote in Parliament
as an individual so why is he not going
to be voting then well obviously because
he's not physically there he doesn't
need to be physically he does let's get
to the core Point here you listed all
the things he's doing my guess is he's
trying to change his career he may not
stand at the next time I think he's
ending as well maybe so it was going to
happen maybe they're going to make him
do the worst possible challenges and
then very quickly boot him maybe so but
think about it this way right you're
mixing up his his performance as a
cabinet minister with the principle of
whether any politics
I'm actually saying both to me are
disqualifying right one he was the
health secretary they're two different
things about well I'm explaining why
both matter right on one count he was
the health secretary presided they were
the worst imaginable pandemic conduct by
government I've seen which is why we had
the worst overall death toll in Europe
in terms of total number killed mostly
in the first wave one he should be held
accountable that before he jollies off
to some jungle and secondly as a serving
MP where we pay a salary he should not
be doing this all right on the first
point we can now pass judgment about uh
Matt Hancock perfectly legitimate
political conversation to have but it's
separate to me separate to the point
that Anne's raised where I disagree but
I respect yourself about whether you can
go on the next step
is how does he vote which is his
constitutional Duty as a member
did you vote on every single vote were
you there on Fridays for a German
debates
the first thing about that Private
Matter the worst thing about it is I
think he waited there was a a an
absolutely
cringe-making clip of Rishi sunac
celebrating becoming prime minister I
don't know if we've got it and it's the
one where he basically goes past and
this is a sadness
thank you
and you know what all right he
completely deliberately sangs Hancock
there but the reality is you'll see what
you want to see no he doesn't I know I
know Richie's doing that trust me he saw
him he started a blanket so but the
point being though if if he hadn't if
he'd embraced Hancock and given him a
new job Hancock would have immediately
abandoned all plans to go to the Jungle
so why should he not be pragmatic about
his future peers
be honest and stand down and pick up two
more years dishonest about him making
that judgment back to my original point
would you have an answered no why don't
he constitutions
he works in this country we elect
members of parliament we the taxpayers
pay their salaries and the very least we
expect is they serve their constituents
and they turn up and vote neither of
which he can do for up to four weeks in
Australia while he's on this ridiculous
vanity exercise of assuming the British
public will suddenly warm to his creepy
little self and vote for him they're not
they're going to vote for him to do
applicable things and then kick him out
because Azan said Azan admitted and I
admit we didn't make it for every single
vote a good a good percentage was about
60 cents he's made a judgmentally the
judge what he's made to be like he's
made many times actually in the last few
years to be utterly self-serving to do
what he thinks is best for Matt Hancock
not anybody else and the result is a
slap in the teeth to the British
taxpayers at a moment when millions of
them are facing the worst cost living
crisis of their of their lifetime
appeals hang on last word to you yes
you've said we didn't all attend every
single vote that is quite true but we
all took judgments on the votes we
attended and let me give you an example
when I was actually moving house that
was the night there was a vote on post
offices I actually got assistance to
move the house while I went to the vote
on post offices if there's a big vote
while he's in the jungle what does he do
yeah well he stays in the jungle I've
got to leave it there look I
in a way limit you're the perfect
example of why you shouldn't be doing
this because your political career could
have been restored you could have
actually rebuilt your career and you
were a very capable politician but the
moment you see munching the old kangaroo
nuts
now Dean Doris did it and she's never
recovered either
come on she got into the cabinet
thank you for coming in I appreciate it
good to see you both